Toda mulher na menopausa que sofre de
osteoporose, será que tem que usar
estradiol? Não necessariamente. A
questão real é outra. Acompanha esse
vídeo para você entender. A terapia
hormonal, ela reduz de fato o risco de
fraturas de 20 a 40% em todos os locais,
sítios ósseos. É o único tratamento
antiosteoporótico eficaz,
independentemente do risco basal. Então,
o mecanismo ocorre pela inibição dos
osteoclastos, que são as células que
comem os ossos, através do aumento de
uma proteína chamada osteoprotegerina.
Para mulheres menores de 60 anos ou
dentro de 10 anos da menopausa,
especialmente se tem fogachos, os
sintomas vasomotores, o estrogênio é a
melhor
opção. Após os 60 anos, a iniciação nem
sempre é recomendada, mas a continuação
pode ser considerada caso a caso. os
riscos tradicionalmente citados de
trombibolismo, né, que é a formação de
coágulos nas artérias e veias, câncer de
mama e eventos
cardiovasculares, aplicam-se aos
hormônios sintéticos orais e não aos
bioidênticos transdérmicos. O estudo WHI
usou estrogênios conjugados de égua e em
conjunto com acetato de medrox
progesterona, que foi a pior combinação
possível.
A progesterona micronizada, ela tem 67%
menos risco de câncer de mama do que as
progestinas sintéticas. O estradiol
transdérmico pela pele evita o
metabolismo hepático e não aumenta os
fatores de coagulação. Então essa
combinação bioidêntica transnêmica é
substancialmente mais segura. Mas aqui
está o ponto crucial que a medicina
convencional ignora. A reposição
bioidêntica só representa risco
significativo para mulheres intoxicadas
com
xenoestrógenos. Que são os
xenoestrógenos? São substâncias
externas, são intoxicantes ambientais,
disruptores endócrinos, estão em
plásticos, cosméticos, agrotóxicos,
produtos de limpeza, alimentos
processados. Ele se acumulam no tecido
gorduroso e compete com receptores
hormonais, criando um ambiente
estrogênico tóxico. A questão dos
chenoestrógenos é muito mais importante
hoje do que privar a mulher de uma
reposição hormonal sendo feita da forma
correta, bioidêntica ao isomolecular.
Estamos, pessoal, focando no problema
errado. Em vez de negar hormônios
bioidênticos às mulheres, deveríamos
estar
desintoxicando-as dos xenoestrógenos
ambientais. O verdadeiro protocolo
deveria incluir primeiro reduzir
exposição a xenoestrógenos, eliminando
plásticos, escolhendo alimentos
orgânicos e usando produtos naturais.
Segundo, apoiar o detox hepático com
nutrientes específicos. Terceiro, só
então iniciar a reposição biidêntica
transdêmica de forma
individualizada. Para vocês terem uma
ideia, a dose ultra baixa de estradiol
transdâmico de 14 mg, que é só 0,014 mg
por dia, já tem eficácia óssea sem
riscos. Para mulheres adequadamente
desintoxicadas, os benefícios
superam riscos que são mínimos. A
decisão sempre tem que ser
individualizada, mas não podemos
continuar privando as mulheres de
hormônios bioidênticos só por medo
baseado em estudos antigos com hormônios
sintéticos, enquanto ignoramos a
verdadeira epidemia de intoxicação por
xeno estrógenos, que está destruindo o
equilíbrio hormonal
feminino. Para aquelas comindicações
absolutas, existem sim casos de
contraindicações
absolutas, existe alternativas como os
bisfosfonados e o denosab, que é o
prolia, mas para a maioria a combinação
de desintoxicação, detox de
xenoestrógenos com reposição bioidêntica
transdérêmica, representa sim a melhor
estratégia terapêutica. Compartilhe os
vídeos, faça bem. A vida de alguém pode
mudar também. no canal do Doutor
Lendá se envolva.